Jaakko do you ever feel burnt out from
going full-tilt several days or several
weeks in a row and if so what do you do
never know of course you know burning
the candle at both ends eventually it's
gonna catch up with you and for me it's
can come in the form of too much travel
too much exercise sometimes I'll just be
pressed at work working with a bunch of
different companies sometimes I'm
writing and I'm trying to get a bunch of
writing done
sometimes I'm training so much jiu-jitsu
it's going crazy
so anyways or a lot of times it's the
combination of all these things going on
at once cuz I'm trying to get a bunch
done in a short amount of time and I end
up whatever coming off the coming off
the track a little bit coming off the
rails a little bit and so what do I do
on those kind of days when I'm starting
to feel like that well number one I like
to force myself to do it anyways that is
a reality so if even if I'm if I don't
feel like working out I'll be like you
know what just go do a quick workout an
easy one easier work out or I don't want
to train jiu-jitsu we were talking about
this earlier don't really feel like
training gonna go train anyways then
maybe there's some form of work that I'm
supposed to do I'm just gonna go and do
the work anyways now if if the next day
I still feel like I need a break that's
sort of my red flag to say alright you
know what you need a break you need to
take some time time relax do some kind
of active rest I don't really like just
kind of sitting around I'll do something
kind of active and probably eat some
steaks plural trying to eat something
really good trying to eat sir just try
you know I might I might eat something
really good like steaks and maybe sleep
take an extra nap try and feel better do
some kind of stretching to try and feel
better just recover just recover so yes
I'm not superhuman like anybody else
sometimes
broken down beaten up and I need some
downtime and that's what I do I try and
rest relax and eat some good food yeah
that's a good on that I start to
incorporate how you were saying if I
don't feel like it or if I feel like I'm
starting to get burnt out you'll you'll
it's like that one last yes yeah let me
just do it anyway yes then I'll see if I
do it you know because sometimes like I
say you avoid the situation were you
just not in the mood
some days you're just not in the mood
but it doesn't mean you're burnt out
you're just not in the mood for whatever
reason so that's a good way to kind of
weed those days out and and yeah if
you're still burnt out the next day or
even the next day after that and it's
like okay you gotta rest I started doing
that and and you'd be surprised what it
how many times you really not burnt out
you're just not in the mood that's a B
you might not agree with this but if you
are like no whether it be burnt out or
just tired of me you know you're just
you just tired of the grind or whatever
and you need a break vacation or
whatever what I sometimes do is don't do
like filming for example where there
would be times where I would spend like
months just filming every week filming
edit it feel like no break and what I do
is don't do any of it and don't think
about it don't just don't do it at all
and then slowly and you in my experience
I was surprised how quick he came back
where you you kind of want to get back
to it but then I go like like a week of
still not doing it it's like jujitsu if
you're like oh man I'm tired of training
every day or whatever you had to turn
him in or whatever and you're like then
I got to take a break after about
probably like three days if you're a
competitor three days you're like man I
want to get back on the mats so what you
do is you push that even more so it's
like you're you're pushing yourself to
be burnt out on the recovery mm-hmm so
the only the only medicine for that
burnt out of recovery is to get back
into it but that hunger of getting back
into it is even more than it normally
would be after a normal break that makes
sense I guess and I just want to call us
and both out right now for being total
cream puffs I think is what Bob often
said here we are talking about how we
get burnt out on working out training
filming it's like Bob Bob Hoffman was
you know living in the seeds of mustard
gas floating around and maybe we should
just say don't get burnt out just work
harder yeah sorry you maybe thought a
real bad there filming no I mean realize
I was like oh I was typing on a computer
I'm real burnt out
shut up Jocko I got a better idea
why don't you just be fired up that you
have the opportunity to create something
how does that sound
oh you got the opportunity to go train
jujitsu to go get better physically oh I
think I'm gonna go ahead and do that I'm
not gonna sit there and say I'm burn out
on training no no don't be burnt out if
Bob Hoffman's not burn out on the
frontlines of World War one I don't
think we have an excuse to be burn out
on the pleasurable things we get to do
in life let's suck it up and just drive
on I'm changing my answer
[Laughter]